a secant line intersects the curve y
equals the natural log of x at two
points with x coordinates two and two
plus h what is the slope of the secant
line well they're giving us two points
on this line it might not be immediately
obvious but they're giving us the points
when x is equal to 2 when x is equal to
2 what is y
well y they tell us y is equal to the
natural log of x so in this case it is
going to be the natural log
of 2. and when x is equal to 2 plus h
what is y well y is always going to be
the natural log of whatever x is so it's
going to be the natural log
of 2
plus h
and so these are two points that sit on
the secant line this happens to be where
the secant line intersects our curve but
these are two points on the line and if
you know two points on a line you will
then be able to figure out the slope of
that line and we can just remind
ourselves that a slope is just change in
y
over
change in x
and so what is this going to be well if
we view the second one as our endpoint
our change in y going from ln of 2 to ln
of 2 plus h
so our change in y is going to be our
endpoint so natural log of 2
plus h minus our starting point or our
end y value minus our starting y value
natural log of 2 and then our change in
x
our change in x is going to be our
ending
our ending x value 2 plus h minus our
starting x value minus 2 and of course
these twos cancel out and if we look
here it looks like we have a choice that
directly matches what we just wrote
this right over here natural log of 2
plus h minus natural log of 2 over h now
if you want to visualize this any a
little bit more we could
we could draw
we could draw a little bit i'm going to
clear this out so i have space to draw
the graph
just so you can really visualize that
this is a secant line so let me draw
my y-axis
and let me draw my
x-axis
and y equals the natural log of x
is going to look
so let me underline that that is going
to look something like this i'm
obviously hand drawing it so not
not a great
drawing
right over here
and so when
when we have so we have the point 2
comma natural log of 2
which would be
let's say it's over
so this is
if this is 2
then this right over here is the natural
log of 2. so that's the point 2 comma
natural log of 2
and then we have some other we just know
it in the abstract 2 plus h so it's 2
plus something so let's say that is 2
plus h
and so this is going to be the point
where we sit on the graph that's going
to be 2 plus h comma the natural log of
2 plus h
and the exercise that we just did is
finding the slope of the line that
connects these two
so the line will look something like
will look something like that and the
way that we did this is we figured out
okay well what is our change in y
so our change in so let's see we are
going from y equals natural log of 2 to
y equals natural log of 2 plus h
so our change in y
our
change in y is our natural log of 2 plus
h
minus natural log of 2
minus natural log of 2 and our change in
x well we're going from 2 to 2 plus h
we're going from 2
to 2 plus h so our change in x we just
increased by h we're going from 2 to 2
plus h so our change in x is equal to h
so the slope of the secant line
the slope of this secant line and secant
it intersects our graph in two points is
going to be change in y over change in x
which is once again exactly what we have
over there